[Music]
a coastal grandmother doesn't care for
thong bodysuits or ketamine yeah her
body can't handle that [ __ ] dude
ketamine oh speaking of ketamine our
friend will he's gay
and we we put together
that kgb
[Music]
he said
oh man
that'd be a great store like
for like
like a gay
oriented like store in in west hollywood
because ketamine there's like a drug
called g which is basically molly yeah
you know
you know it is g yeah ghb
i've never done it i just
have
heard about it i've always known ghb is
like a predatory drug yeah yeah yeah
it's like a
it but also a lot of gay men do it and
then b for blow okay and then we were
joking like the kgb is actually a crazy
like ballroom experience
like lennon just closes that door it's
just like like 100 kgb operatives and
they just start playing ballroom and
they're just voguing and they're just
going crazy
what
kgb
yeah yeah and blood what do you mean
voguing what is that bruh
like
just
what does voguing mean bro i i'm not
gonna explain you need to experience
okay what is it just give me a
give me a just a gist
it's like
yeah it's like types of improvisational
dance inspired by the poses of models in
fashion magazines okay when you read
some of the comments
on the tick tocks where like these
performers go out and vogue yeah like
yeah this is this is what lennon was
doing yeah with the kgb okay yeah yeah
when you read the comments on some of
the tick tocks for these performers it's
[ __ ] brutal like the the crowds are
very cutthroat if you are not serving if
it's not
giving anything
take your [ __ ] ass
off the stage like take get okay there
is zero tolerance
for
like
low quality performance you're saying
the comments on tick tock oh yeah of
like on clips from these shoes yeah dude
get man
i i'm like can we find some i've just
gone down a
rabbit hole with
ballroom stuff and
it just makes me think like damn
psychologically you have to have so much
mental toughness
damn that's [ __ ] crazy yeah this
person goes up [ __ ] murders like that
and then you gotta go up after yeah
and if you're even an ounce of doo doo
the crowd will let you know
you're just sitting there like trying to
like no no it's this is good just wait
it's gonna get better and everyone's
like nah oh damn no this is ass they
just set up a catwalk and then it's like
a vogue voguing event well the origins
of
ballroom and so on i think
it's like
historically
it's like um
i would i think it'd be considered like
black art like
and so it has like a long history to it
and so essentially yeah
i think it started in ballrooms like
because that's like the genre of music
or a style of music that they play um
and if anyone has this better than me
chime in but
yeah so i think now
i don't know at what point the catwalk
was introduced but it's like sometimes
it'll be in a ballroom and sometimes
yeah it'll be somewhere they just set up
a stage
and
people crowd around the stage what kind
of music is it
it's um
[Music]
the music has crazy ass energy
so he's so you're saying the comments
like when people [ __ ] up or brutal oh
someone's ass yeah yeah really yeah
that's that's funny yeah like it'll be
like it's giving nothing all capitals
my god god damn dude
oh man the internet is just ruthless no
matter what
i don't i don't know why specifically
with
with um
like ballroom and voguing like
i don't know why it just makes me laugh
seeing all these people go
it's giving nothing and then like a
hundred follow-up comments like honestly
the like i the lack of energy is
apparent like just
it's very dialed in mean [ __ ]
and this is this looks so hard a super
yeah super duper so hard nah
it's you cannot like that's what i mean
the the confidence to even attempt to
get on the stage
the confidence to even try that move
without anybody there yeah
just landed on her back yeah
should we try it
[ __ ] go for it dude
[Applause]
yeah it's giving nothing
it's giving no rhythm
yeah man how do they do that that for
how did you do that move i mean like
it's like it's like a pivot off of the
ball of your heel i think
and then i think they use their it's
kind of like that
you know in wrestling when they're
trying to teach us how to do that fall
yeah i think it's a similar practice
yeah yeah
but i think what's different you kind of
broke or fall with like the
yeah and then that and then the hand
yeah the hand reaching out yeah
but i think what's more impressive is
she hits that and then she pops back up
yeah
anyways the kgb
i just
[ __ ]
i imagine how offended
you just set up a store called kgb
and you just yasify
communist leaders it's like what the
[ __ ] is this
welcome to kgb
you